la suède sacré pour la troisième fois
championne du monde de golf par équipes
ingrid lindblad meilhat horton grain et
louise reid beast remporte les mondiaux
amateurs qui se déroulait au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines et
à saint nom la bretèche une dernière
journée indécise samedi à st nom la
suède et les états unis qui terminent
deuxièmes ont été départagés par la
meilleure carte de la troisième joueuse
louise arriviste l'allemagne et le japon
complètent le podium à la troisième
place ex-aequo la jeune équipe de france
elle termine à une belle 11e place la
suite de ces championnats du monde
amateurs par équipes de mercredi à
samedi pour le tournoi messieurs
toujours à saint quentin en yvelines et
saint nom la bretèche
le football-club de versailles se
relance dans la troisième journée de
national victoire 2 à 0 contre
bourg-en-bresse et rona à vendredi à
jean bouin djoko ouvre le score juste
avant la fin de la première mi temps son
premier but cette saison tout comme le
borgne qui inscrit le deuxième but peu
avant l'heure de jeu un match engagé
trois expulsions au total deux côtés
bourg peronnas une pour versailles au
classement les yvelinois remonte à la 4e
place à un seul point du leader
concarneau prochain match vendredi
versailles se déplace à orléans
[Musique]
voici cartonnent en ce début de saison
en nationale 2 deuxième succès en deux
matches pour les pisciacais ce samedi
sur la pelouse de blois les deux buts
marqués en toute fin de rencontre que
dont celui de tours est déjà à trois
réalisations cette saison après deux
journées poissy est premier ex-aequo du
groupe à de nationale 2 6 points tout
comme le racing club de france et rouen